Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Sin agua, un ser humano
solo puede sobrevivir unas 100 horas.
Pero hay una criatura tan resistente
que puede estar sin ella durante décadas.
Este animal de un milímetro
puede sobrevivir
en los ambientes más cálidos
y los más fríos de la Tierra,
e incluso puede soportar
altos niveles de radiación.
Este es el tardígrado,
y es una de las criaturas
más fuertes en la Tierra,
aunque tenga la apariencia de
un osito gordito de goma de 8 patas.
La mayoría de los organismos
necesitan agua para sobrevivir.
El agua permite que
se realice el metabolismo,
que es el proceso que lleva a
todas las reacciones bioquímicas
que tienen lugar en las células.
Pero las criaturas como el tardígrado,
también conocido como oso de agua,
se saltan esta restricción
mediante un proceso llamado anhidrobiosis,
del griego y que significa vida sin agua.
Y sin embargo, estos tardígrados
extraordinarios no están solos.
Las bacterias,
los organismos unicelulares
llamados arqueas,
las plantas,
e incluso otros animales
pueden sobrevivir a toda desecación.
Para muchos tardígrados,
esto requiere que pasen por algo
que se llama estado de tonel.
Se enroscan en una bola,
plegando la cabeza y las 8 ocho patas
dentro de su cuerpo
a esperar hasta que vuelva el agua.
Se cree que a medida
que el agua se vuelve escasa
y los tardígrados entran
en su estado tonel,
empiezan a sintetizar
moléculas especiales,
que llenan las células del tardígrado
para reemplazar el agua perdida
mediante la formación de una matriz.
Los componentes de las células
que son sensibles a la sequedad,
como el ADN,
las proteínas,
y las membranas,
quedan atrapados en esta matriz.
Se cree que esto mantiene
esas moléculas bloqueadas en la posición
para detener el despliegue,
la ruptura,
o la fusión.
Una vez que se rehidrata
el organismo, la matriz se disuelve,
dejando células
en buen estado y funcionales.
Más allá de la sequedad,
los tardígrados también pueden
tolerar otras condiciones extremas:
ser congelados,
calentados más allá
del punto de ebullición del agua,
altos niveles de radiación,
e incluso el vacío del espacio exterior.
Esto ha llevado a
una especulación errónea
de que los tardígrados
son seres extraterrestres.
Aunque es divertido pensarlo,
la evidencia científica pone
firmemente su origen en la Tierra
donde han evolucionado con el tiempo.
De hecho, esta evolución terrestre
ha dado lugar
a más de 1100 especies
conocidas de tardígrados
y es probable que haya muchas
otras aún por descubrir.
Y como los tardígrados son tan
resistentes, existen en casi todas partes.
Viven en todos los continentes,
incluida la Antártida.
Y están en diversos biomas,
incluyendo los desiertos,
la capa polar,
el mar,
el agua dulce,
las selvas tropicales,
y en los más altos picos.
Pero también se pueden encontrar
tardígrados en los lugares más comunes,
como el musgo o los líquenes
que hay en los patios,
los parques,
y los bosques.
Todo lo necesario para encontrarlos es
un poco de paciencia y un microscopio.
Los científicos intentan averiguar, si
los tardígrados utilizan el estado tonel,
su técnica antisecado,
para sobrevivir
otras condiciones de estrés.
Si podemos entender cómo,
ellos y otras criaturas,
estabilizan sus moléculas
biológicas sensibles,
tal vez se podría usar ese conocimiento
para ayudar a estabilizar las vacunas,
o para desarrollar
cultivos tolerantes al estrés
que pueden hacer frente
a los cambios climáticos de la Tierra.
Y mediante el estudio
de cómo sobreviven los tardígrados
a la exposición prolongada
al vacío del espacio exterior,
los científicos pueden obtener pistas
sobre los límites ambientales de la vida
y la forma de proteger
a los astronautas.
Los tardígrados pueden incluso ayudar
a responder a una pregunta fundamental:
¿podría sobrevivir la vida en planetas
mucho menos hospitalarios que el nuestro?